تحت مجهر القضاءين اللبناني والاوروبي بات
حاكم مصر في لبنان المركزي فرياض سلامي
الذي يراس البنك المركزي منذ 30 عاما
يواجه دعاوى قضائيه محليه بعد ان سبقتها
اخرى خارجيه مع بدء الانهيار الاقتصادي في
لبنان ادعاء نيابه العامه في بيروت على
سلام تضمن شبهات بجرائم اختلاس الاموال
العامه والاسراء غير المشروع وتبييض
الاموال اما التحقيقات القضائيه الاوروبيه
فترتبط بشبهه تبييض نحو 300 مليون دولار
تم ايداعها في مصارف غربيه
شبهات ينفيها حاكم البنك المركزي اللبناني
الذي قال انه بريء وسيمثل امام قاضي
التحقيق مؤكدا ان الادعاءات الموجهه اليه
لا تمثل لائحه اتهام هكذا اذا بات رياض
سلامي امام مساريني قضائيين متوازيين
يتقاطعان عند شبهه قيامه مع مساعداته
ماريان حويك وشقيقه الذي يمتلك شركه ماليه
بتبويض مئات ملايين دولارات بين لبنان
ودول اوروبيه
لكن حقوقيين يخشون من ان يؤدي مسار القضيه
الى تعطيل المحاولات الاوروبيه لملاحقه
سلامي لا سيما ان حاكم المصرف المركزي
يتمتع برايهم بغطاء سياسي قد يكون هناك
نوع من الطبخه السياسيه القضائيه ونحن
نتمنى ان لا تكون موجوده بهدف تمييع هذا
التحقيق
وتاخيره ايضا يهدف تجاه تاخير التحقيقات
الاوروبيه
فالمسار القضائي اللبناني لا سقف زمنيا له
اذ يحق لسلامي تقديم دفوع لوقف التحقيقات
ما قد يدخلها في مسار مشابه لتحقيقات
انفجار مرفا بيروت
مخاوف كان الشارع اللبناني قد عبر عنها من
خلال احتجاجات ضد السلطه الحاكمه وكيفيه
مقاربتها للملفات السياسيه والماليه لا
سيما تلك التي يتبعها المصرف المركزي
ايهاب العقد الجزيره بيروت